this video is made possible by vince
arrow watches luxury handcrafted watches
at their prices you can check them out
at vince arrow watches dot-com /bi
graphics dear boss grands work the last
job was I gave the lady no time to
squeal how can they catch me now I love
my work I want to start again you will
soon hear of me with my funny little
games my knifes so nice and sharp I want
to get to work right away if I get a
chance good luck yours truly Jack the
Ripper
those were extracts from a letter that
London's Central News Agency received on
September the 27th 1888 he was then
forwarded to Scotland Yard who were in
the middle of investigating perhaps the
most notorious killing spree of all time
someone was attacking women in
Whitechapel murdering them and then
cutting up their bodies in gruesome
fashion the killer went by many names
the Whitechapel murderer leather aprons
saucy Jack and of course Jack the Ripper
he remains as unidentified to this day
so we will focus on his grim body of
work the murders the suspects the
investigators few if any other killers
in history have inspired so many studies
books and hypotheses courtesy of police
officers historians writers and crime
buffs who are collectively known as
Ripper ologists yes
today on biographic s-- we explore the
life of Jack the Ripper
[Music]
in 1888 the Whitechapel parish in the
East End of London was a place rife with
crime it was an overcrowded low-income
area with terrible housing and terrible
working conditions there was a brothel
on every corner and a bar next to every
brothel so the residents could indulge
their vices and forget about their
poverty-stricken lives but even for such
an area nobody was prepared for what
they were about to discover early one
morning on August the 31st a man named
Charles cross was on his way to his job
on bucks Row on the way he found a woman
lying prone in the street with a skirt
raised above her waist cross and another
man named Robert Paul approached her and
touched her head and hands unable to
decide if she was dead or merely
unconscious the two concluded that they
should pull down her skirts and they
would alert the first police officer
that they encountered but otherwise
while they had jobs to get to the
streets of Whitechapel were poorly lit
and it was still night outside in the
darkness even up close neither man
noticed that the woman's throat had been
slit and her abdomen mutilated a police
constable named John Neal came upon the
body followed closely by constable mizen
who had been alerted by cross a third
constable went to fetch the doctor the
physician pronounced the woman dead and
concluded that she had been killed about
half an hour prior this meant that the
killer was likely still in the area when
Charles cross Walker by the victim was
Mary Ann Nichols a prostitute who also
went by Polly that first her murder was
linked to a few other killings which
we'll talk about a bit later
while some blames a violent gang the
newspapers around the story of one
deranged killer preying on these women
in the weeks that followed street gossip
created the belief that the killer was a
local Jewish man known as a leather
apron why trouble had a large Jewish
population so resentment against them
was high of course the newspapers were
more than happy to fuel the
sensationalism whether it was due to
frustration incompetence or outside
pressure to do something the police
decided to arrest John Peyser in
September he was a Polish Jew who worked
as a shoemaker and some said that he was
sometimes called leather apron he also
had a prior conviction for a stabbing
attack
this was all the police had against
Peyser but fortunately for Peyser he had
a solid alibi that excavated him Pfizer
even won a libel case against a
newspaper that are declared him to be
the killer
[Music]
on September the 8th the Whitechapel
murderer struck again when the body of
any Chapman was found in the backyard of
Danbury Street by an elderly resident he
flagged down some passing workmen who
alerted the police
Chapman's throat had a deep cut in her
body had been mutilated with multiple
stab wounds immediately suggesting a
connection with the murder of Mary
Nichols she had been disemboweled and
her intestines had been severed lifted
out of the body and placed on her
shoulder a later post-mortem examination
revealed that the killer had removed and
taken Chapman's uterus dr. George Baxter
Phillips examines the wounds and
ascertains that they were caused by a
very long sharp knife with a long thin
narrow blade it could have been the
surgical instruments that a doctor might
use for a post mortem Phillips also said
in his testimony that the murderer
showed indications of anatomical
knowledge these conclusions gave birth
to the idea that the killer might be
someone with a medical backgrounds a
notion that is still pervasive today the
murders caused a huge sensation in
London and were discussed in every
newspaper in the city meanwhile the
police had to contend with an unexpected
problem that significantly impeded their
already plotting investigation they had
to look in to hundreds of letters that
they received from the public broadly
these missives could be placed into two
categories letters from people offering
suggestions or information on how to
catch the culprit and letters alleged to
be from the killer himself the police
received upwards of 700 letters from the
public hundreds were purportedly
from the Whitechapel murderer either
taunting or expressing remorse for his
actions that being said there are a few
which sharply even by many investigators
to have some merit the first one we
mentioned in the introduction to this
video there was sent to the Central News
Agency almost 20 days after the murder
of Annie Chapman it starts with the
words dear boss and ends with the
murderer giving himself a name from now
on he would be known as Jack the Ripper
at first the dear boss letter was
dismissed as a hoax like all the others
however one particular phrase garnered
the interest of the police when talking
about his next job jag said that he
would clip the lady's ears off this
became relevant when just a few days
later the killer did just that on
September the 30th two women a fell
victim to the Ripper Elizabeth stride
and Catherine Eddowes first off was
Elizabeth stride also known as long Liz
she was last seen around midnight in the
company of an unidentified man she was
killed soon after that and her body had
already been discovered by 1:00 a.m. at
duck fields yard on burner Street
Liz died from a long six inch gash in
her neck but she suffered no mutilation
because of this some master reticent to
counter as a Ripper victim believing
that she could have been the target of
an unrelated attack however others
consider that there are enough
similarities such as location and
killing method to group her in with the
other women they believe that Jack did
not cut up her body because he was
either rushing to kill again or perhaps
because he was interrupted this is where
a Hungarian Jew named Israel Schwartz
came in with an interesting story to
share which if true men see might have
been the interrupter Schwartz told
police that he saw a man assaulted women
on burner Street at around 12:45 a.m.
that night believing he was witnessing a
domestic spat between husband and wife
he wanted nothing to do with it and
cross the street to avoid them
he later identified long Liz as the
woman that he saw that night his
cowardice was subsequently mocked in
newspapers which labelled Schwartz an
hearted creature well there are two
peculiar details about his story firstly
Schwartz claims that there was a second
man in the vicinity smoking a pipe
secondly the witness said that the
attacker saw him and shouted something
at him Schwartz believed the word was
Lipsky and anti-semitic slur which
referenced Israel Lipsky Jewish man
hanged for murder the year before we
don't know how serious police took
Schwartz his accounts but they did not
call on him to testify at the inquest
their records do indicate that they
tracked down and eliminated the second
man as a suspect meanwhile within
walking distance of burner Street Jack
had found himself another victim called
Catherine Kate Edo's after midnight Kate
was walking the streets of London
after being released from jail for
drunken behavior she ended up in mitre
square ins was last seen alive at around
1:30 a.m. in the company of a man by
three Jewish gentlemen leaving a club on
Duke Street one of those three Joseph
Luanne day got a decent look at the
couple and described them although he
mainly remembered their clothes and not
their features a dozes body was
discovered soon after by a constable
walking his beat her neck had been cut
and her body had suffered gruesome
mutilations more extensive than any of
the previous victims
her face was disfigured her intestines
were removed and placed on her shoulder
and the killer had removed her left
kidney and part of her uterus jacket
also cut off Kate's right here which is
what convinced authorities that the dear
boss letter was the genuine article now
just before we get into the other
letters that the police had to deal with
let me tell you about today's sponsor
Vince arrow then Sarah creates
exceptionally crafted timepieces at fair
prices these watches they're
great-looking pieces
certainly not minimalistic like you see
with a lot of online watch companies
these days rather their bowls they have
a very distinct look rather than just
sort of blending in and looking like
every other watch out there what I'm
wearing today this is their altitude
watch I'll throw up some b-roll so you
can get a better look at it if you
couldn't tell from the name this is a
pilot's watch obviously and it's a it's
quite different to some of the other
stuff that they've done I rather like it
it's got this very nice that I sub dials
it's got a dual time zone function I
really like the red second hands you
know very pilot watch esque also this
nylon strap solid I like nylon straps so
watch is also built for adventure it's
got so far coated mineral crystal glass
stainless steel case it's designed to
take a few bumps this thing anyway
holiday is coming up next month perfect
time to pick out I've been cero watch
for yourself or a friends or family
member men's and women's watches are
available and you can get it engraved
too which really makes it an ideal gift
write a special message to someone that
you love go check out the full range up
in Sarah watches dot-com /bi graphics
use the code bio graphics on check out
for a special discount link below let's
get back to Jack
speaking of letters the next day the
central news agency received a postcard
the text said I was not cutting dear old
boss when I gave you the tip your hair
about saucy Jackie's worked Moreau
double events this time number one
squealed a bit couldn't finish straight
off had not time to get ears off the
police thanks for keeping last letter
back till I got to work again
Jack the Ripper the details in the
handwriting suggested to police not only
that the postcard was real but that it
was written by the same person who wrote
the dear boss letter they published a
facsimile in the hope that someone might
recognize the handwriting but they were
unsuccessful unfortunately while it is
true that both were probably written by
the same person it is also possible that
that person was not Jack the Ripper
since the start some investigators
believed that these letters were the
work of journalists specifically either
fredbear scott thomas bullying they had
access to confidential information who
wanted to keep interest in Jack alive
indeed it is quite feasible that all the
correspondence purported to be from Jack
the Ripper was actually written by other
people who wanted to be a part of the
sick charade that surrounded the murders
one more letter does merit inclusion
there because it came with a grisly
accessory part of a human kidney this
missive was addressed from hell and was
sent to George Lusk chairman of a
volunteer the jalan tea group calls the
Whitechapel vigilance committee it read
mr. Lusk sad I said you half the kidney
I took from one woman preserved it for
Utah the piece I fried and ate and it
was very nice I may send you the bloody
knife that took it out if you only wait
a while longer
signs catch me when you can mr. Lusk
the handwriting in this letter was
definitely not the same as the first two
obviously the implication was that the
kidney belonged to the fourth victim
Catherine Eddowes dr. Thomas Openshaw of
the London hospital examines the organ
and concluded that it was indeed human
subsequently Openshaw received his own
Ripper letter where Jack lamented that
coppers spoiled of the game and foiled
his attempts to claim another victim
near openshaw's hospital
Jack the Ripper saved his most vicious
kills for last his victim was Mary Jane
Kelly an Irish working girl who had only
25 years old was much younger than the
other murdered women also unlike the
rest she was killed in her home rather
than on the street Kelly's body was
discovered on the morning of November
the 9th at her lodging at 13 Miller's
Court by Thomas Bauer her landlord
sistent Bauer came round to collect the
rent and even though he was a former
soldier he was left stunned by the scene
of ineffable horror that awaited him
first thing he noticed was the broken
window inside the room was absolutely
covered in blood on the table he saw
piles of meat not realizing in the
moment that they were human flesh on the
bed there was the body of Kelly which
had been so grotesquely maimed and
mangled that it barely looked human
anymore according to the doctors
estimation it would have taken around 2
hours to inflict those atrocities upon
Mary Kelly it showed the world just how
to pray of to Jack the Ripper could be
when he had all the time and privacy
that he wanted police surgeon dr. Thomas
bond detailed the extent of her injuries
in his report all of the surface of the
abdomen and thighs were removed and the
abdominal cavity emptied of its viscera
the breasts were cut off the arms
mutilated by several jagged wounds and
the face hacked beyond recognition of
the features the tissues of the neck
were severed or round to the bone
[Music]
on the other side of the law the London
police force was engaged in one of the
most ample investigations in its history
thousands of people were interviewed and
hundreds of leads were chased down yet
police were heavily criticised by the
public in the media for failing to
apprehend the killer the inquiry was
initially handled by a whitechapel's h
division of the criminal investigation
department but was soon taken over by
Scotland Yard detectives chief among
them was Detective Inspector Frederick
abberline who was put in charge of the
case because he had previously worked
for age division for 14 years and it was
thought that his local knowledge would
prove invaluable a frequent criticism
throughout the investigation concerned
police refusal to offer a reward for
information authorities were accused
either of not taking the case seriously
or not caring what happens in a poor
district full of immigrants like
Whitechapel in reality this lack of
reward was a new Home Office policy
instituted a few years earlier now if
you're watching this video you're
probably already aware that the police
never caught Jack the Ripper that being
said there are two curious moments in
their investigation that are worth
discussing first is a report by surgeon
Thomas bond he was asked for his opinion
on the killer's medical knowledge but
bond ended up writing an 11-point essay
which is sometimes regarded as the first
ever criminal profile curiously bond
vehemently disagreed with dr. Phillips
assertion that Jack the Ripper had a
medical background he didn't even think
the killer had the technical knowledge
of a butcher or horse slaughterer
moreover bond had no doubt that the five
women were killed by the same hands he
concluded that Jack the Ripper was cool
daring middle-aged quiet respectably
dressed and inoffensive looking he
believes the killer wore a cloak or a
fur coat in order to conceal the
bloodstains after the murders bond said
this in each case the mutilation was the
Ripper's main goal and that Jack may
have suffered from homicidal impulses
brought on by satirizes condition better
known today as hypersexuality on
nymphomaniac
the second moment concerns the only clue
that Jack the Ripper left following a
kill after he murdered Catherine Eddowes
he took her apron police later found the
bloodied garment in a stairwell on
Goulston Street right above it was a
piece of graffiti written in chalk which
read the
Jews are the men that will not be blamed
for nothing police saw it copied it down
and on the orders of police commission
at Charles Warren wiped clean at a time
of sky-high racial tension see feared
that the text might incite a violent
riot much debate still goes on regarding
whether the police acted properly by
erasing possible evidence and whether
the graffiti was actually a message from
Jack the Ripper or just a random
anti-semitic scrawl unconnected to the
crimes
[Music]
the five dead women we have mentioned
are referred to by Ripper ologists as
the canonical five and aren't generally
considered Jack's only victims however
given the uncertainty surrounding
everything else related to the Ripper
it's not surprising that people think he
may have killed others first there were
two slangs which took place in
Whitechapel before that of Mary Nichols
the first victim was Emma Smith and the
second was Martha Tabram Smith survived
terror attacked long enough to tell the
police she was assaulted by two or three
men making it more likely that she fell
prey to gang violence Tabram however
died after being stabbed 39 times her
kill had the viciousness of Jack the
Ripper but investigators were ultimately
convinced that her death was unrelated
because her throat was in cartons she
wasn't mutilated afterwards even so it
wouldn't be completely unheard of for a
serial killer to evolve his murder
sovereigns I and increase in brutality
as he gained more experience and more
confidence for more suspicious deaths
occurred in 1888 and 1889 which were
added to the Whitechapel murders however
they were considered unrelated because
they lacked the savage disfigurement of
the Ripper that said one of those
victims was just the Tor sewer for women
that certainly sounds vicious enough to
be the work of Jack but as it happens
for other torsos had been found around
that time just not in Whitechapel only
one of the victims of the so-called
Thames torso murders was identified as
Elizabeth Jackson some believe these
were all the work of Jack while others
feel they belonged to a second maniac
who was active at the same time as the
Ripper so who was Jack the Ripper that's
the million-dollar question and
historians scholars criminologists
authors and police officers have put
forward over a hundred suspects
Inspector abberline strongly suspected
George Chapman a Polish immigrants and
convicted serial killer who was hanged
for three poisonings Chapman real name's
Severn Klossowski had minor surgical
knowledge and arrives in London shortly
before the killing spree started he also
left for America in 1891 a few years
after the murders stopped however
Chapman used poison and criminologists
don't believe a killer would change
their modus operandi to
such an extent another convicted serial
killer suspected of being Jack was dr.
Thomas Neil cream he was also a poisoner
and according to records he was in
prison in America during the killing
spree all available evidence should
dismiss screams candidate yet he remains
a popular choice solely based on the
story that while being hanged Queens
last words were allegedly I am Jack a
more plausible suspect was Aaron
Kosminski a Jewish barber who emigrated
from Congress Poland sometime in the
early 1880s he was considered a strong
candidate by several authorities of that
e-rep sir Melvin Manhattan Assistant
Commissioner of the London Metropolitan
Police wrote in memoranda that kozminski
had strong homicidal tendencies and a
great hatred of women especially of the
prostitute class chief inspector Donald
Swanson wrote that the only witness who
got a good look at the rippers face
doesn't specify who but presumably
either Schwartz solo and a refused to
testify against him because they were
both Jewish and although we're not
exactly sure on the date sometime around
1890 kozminski was committed to an
insane asylum which lines up with a
murder stopping modern science seemingly
came to the rescue when a paper
published in the Journal of Forensic
Sciences boldly proclaimed that Aaron
Kosminski
was Jack the Ripper based on DNA the
author's alleged that a semen sample
obtained from the shawl of Catherine
Eddowes the fourth victim was DNA
matched to a living relative of
Kosminski this study however was heavily
criticized by other scientists who found
many faults with it even the provenance
of the Shaw is in doubt the original
inventory done in 1888 and detailed
lists over 30 items of clothing and
possessions that Eddowes had honor at
the time of the murder yet there is no
shawl among them so while Kosminski
remains one of the top suspects the
matter is yet to be settled in the same
memoranda resisting commissioner
McNaughton name's montague jurors his
favorite suspects he asserted that
Drouet was sexually insane and was
suspected of being the Ripper even by
his own family drew it to committed
suicide a month after the murder of Mary
Kelly giving a reason why the murders
stopped McNaughton's appraisal placed
Drouet at the top of the suspect list of
many Ripper ologists but it seems to be
based on mostly incorrect facts and
hearsay inspector abberline dismissed
Drouet as a suspect and decade
later researchers placed drew it in
different parts of the country for some
of the murders going by viciousness
alone a man named Frederick Bailey
Deming seemed to be the most likely
culprit Deming was hanged in Australia
in 1892 for killing his second wife only
for it to be later discovered that he
had also murdered his first wife and
their four children by cutting their
throats
he was certainly capable of inflicting
the gruesome horrors of the Ripper but
records of his movements in 1888 up
spotty at best they seemed to indicate
that Deming was in South Africa at the
time these are just a few of the more
sensible suspects there are many more
out there some believed the killings
were the work of a Masonic conspiracy
involving the royal family whose goal
was to protect Prince Albert Victor and
that the killer was either the prince
himself or the queen's physician Sir
William gull others applied that the
murderer was Lewis Carroll author of
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland or the
post-impressionist painter Walter
Sickert some believe that Jack the
Ripper was in fact Jill the Ripper and
that the killer was a woman this theory
started with Inspector abberline himself
some of the suspects included women of
the era who had been convicted of
heinous murders such as Mary Pearcey and
Lizzie Holliday now we could keep doing
this all day and would definitely not
run out of suspects ultimately there
isn't sufficient evidence to identify
beyond a shadow of a doubt any person as
Jack the Ripper this anonymity surely
helped bolster his infamy as well here
we are a hundred and thirty years after
his ghastly killing spree still talking
about it and we are hardly the only ones
books movies and TV shows that revolve
around the Ripper murders are still
popular today so that leaves us with
just one question who do you think was
Jack the Ripper so I already have you
found their video suitably horrifying if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe also please do check out our
sister channel Geographics if you
enjoyed this video which is about person
this channel does people enjoy
Geographics as well it does places there
is a link below and thank you for
watching
[Music]